THE JUNE TWENTY SIX. TWENTY
TWENTY HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE. NOW WE HAVE A QUORUM
GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON ALL THAT
STUFF MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL BERMAN HERE
BERMAN HERE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER HERE CALDERON LOW LOW
HERE MAYES MAYES HERE MULLIN
MULLIN FEAR WEBER WEBER HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DUE TO THE CURRENT
STATE HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON CONSISTENT
WITH THE CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF
THE HOUSE THE PEOPLE
PARTICIPATING COMMITTEE
HEARINGS MUST BE PROPERLY
ATTIRED WE ARE REQUIRING THAT
ALL THOSE ATTENDING THE TEARING
PERSON MUST WERE COVERING HIS
THERE'S JUST. I'M ON THE
COMMITTEE THE GENDER TODAY AND
THAT IS THAT THE PROCEDURAL
ITEM SO WE WILL NOT BE TAKING
TESTIMONY I REMEMBER WHAT SB
FOUR TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR
UMBERG IS BEFORE SAID IS SOLELY
FOR THE PURPOSE ADOPTING OFFICE
AND ITS TOP OF THOSE AND
ANALYSIS THE AMENDMENTS HAVE
PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OFFICES ARE VERY LONG THESE
WEBSITE BECAUSE I MISSED Z.
POSITIVE CANNOT BE ADOPT OUT
THE COMMITTEE. RULES COMMITTEE
OF THIS AND SEE CLOUT THIS BILL
TWENTY TWO I'M OCEAN MEN WILL
HAVE A MUCH INTEREST IN. HAVE A
SECOND. SIR PLEASE CALL THE-
VOTE. THE IS TO AMANDA RE REFER
TO THE CA ON ALLOW AND READ.
BERMAN HI BERMAN I GOT.
GALLAGHER I CALDERON LOW LOW HI
MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN MULLIN
AYE WEBER WEBER HI. THAT'S
GREAT. THIS EVENT PASSES WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR ABOUT FIVE MINUTES-
MEMBERS APOLOGIES FOR BEING A
COUPLE MINUTES LATE APPRECIATE
YOUR BEING HERE MEETINGS
ADJOURNED.
AT THE TOP OF THE
OKAY ON THE AMENDMENTS CALDERON
HI. THANK YOU THINK THAT OKAY.